hi everyone I'm Austin Rose Way and I
probably should have come in and gotten
this set up a little bit earlier but
here we are I'm a principal research
designer and I'm a little bit of a
different animal as you will soon find
out I am working in the urban innovation
initiative I am a co-founder of did you
girls tech camp does anyone know did you
girls okay there's yeah a few okay and
also co-founder of the artists and
residents that I currently run today so
just to give you some context I grew up
in an art family do you guys you guys
have any art parents out there parents
that are artists no well it's a totally
different thing so my background was
primarily in fine arts and then as an
act of rebellion I decided to get into
graphic design so half of my life has
been spent in paint and pass telling and
sculpture and the other half of my life
has been working through digital design
user experience and now working in
Microsoft Research so how did I end up
in Microsoft Research I'm sure that's on
everyone's minds right yes um a little
bit of serendipitous Ness I was invited
to come in and work on virtual worlds
technology so this was the first ever
instantiated Fortnight experience back
in late 90s and they wanted me to build
and create virtual environments that
people could go around and sort of
communicate via avatars so you have to
understand that in 1999 that was kind of
bonkers right like we had modems like
you guys look up modems it's crazy
it took forever to get a signal and the
poly count was so heavy and so they had
me come in and work in the space and
honestly as a graphic designer I was
blown away and it was a rabbit hole that
I just had to go down and that has been
my career ever since and as you can see
the influence from my art background my
sort of fine arts background and my sort
of user experience has led me to create
these hybrid next-generation sense
seeing materials wearables that I've
been doing for the last maybe 10 years
in research so anything from talking to
your plants having conversations the
interspecies IOT scenarios so not about
your car talking to your garage but you
talking to a plant talking to an animal
those are the futures that I want so I'm
pushing these kind of narratives in
addition to using color metric sensing
to actually change colors to infer that
you're being exposed to hazards like CO
or or you know maybe some kind of
bacteria so as you can see on the the
far right
that's color metric hair and that
actually works so you if you want if you
treat your hair with these strands you
can walk outside and your hair color
will change in intensity depending on
the intensity of the UV index so the
idea is that we're turning people into
sensors for the environment and biklen
will be here for lunch
she's our chemist so you should totally
ask her about the hair so as I said I
work in the urban innovation initiative
and this is very much of the team effort
across research everyone here who just
can't sleep at night because the climate
change is coming together to tackle
these really tough problems and so as
you can see we have different pockets in
our efforts anywhere from data analytics
to a new sensor and hardware design to
HCI research and user studies so just
you know FYI we're always looking for
interns so look us up we're awesome and
so our first big project is around air
quality the thing that eludes us about
air quality and air pollution is that we
just really can't see it until it's
really bad and affects us every day and
it's in fact it's getting worse and
worse so how can we leverage the natural
world especially in chemistry to start
revealing the things that we get exposed
to every day but not only that how does
this sort of drive the sort of hyper
local narrative that I can actually
detect things based on where I'm walking
where I'm going
because all of the stuff is going to
inform how we want to drive policy
around pollution going forward so um
this is eco bits this is our first air
quality sensor we're deploying we're
actually deploying it this week in a
city on the East Coast so fingers
crossed because we have no idea how
that's going to go down but what we're
excited about is not only the data that
we're gonna get from it but the
experiences we can drive with it so
imagine putting on you know an augmented
reality headset and looking around the
city and seeing the air quality in
real-time those are the kind of
scenarios were excited about this is our
gas tank testing unit so we're actually
pumping in real gases like nitrogen
you know sulfur dioxides and carbon
monoxides and we're calibrating these
things and then this is just another
wave that we're doing we're exploring
ways that we can augment chemical
sensing with backscatter technologies to
come up with the next wave of low cost
sensors because we know that these
sensors are very expensive for people
for cities so we're also looking into
ways that we can make them cheap and
affordable and get them in the hands of
everyone okay so how many of you have
seen the giant egg out there yeah okay
so this is part of our artisan residents
as a patron of the art I feel that art
actually helps inform us about our
humanity and how the technologies we
develop actually will impact the world
in a in a realistic way
so ADA is a collaboration that we've
done with Jennie Savin she is a Dean of
architecture at Cornell and her schtick
is that she has been using
next-generation materials and
technologies to generate these sort of
super organic form functions and the
idea is that she'd she's envisioning a
world where you know your dwellings
could actually shift through material to
fight you know for instance if you've
got extreme temperatures right then the
walls in your house can sort of shift
themselves to accommodate if it's
overheated or too
holds she's very interested in that
space and ADA is really an exploration
around AI right cuz I don't know about
you guys you guys are all really super
smart so you probably know what AI is
but for the bulk of people in the world
it's a black box nobody understands what
it's about so we wanted to integrate
this notion of AI into embedded
materials and we want to have a very
transparent conversation about what that
means and how that impacts our lives so
I'm going to show you video hopefully
it'll work if it doesn't I have backup
slides let's see ADA is driven by
artificial intelligence it's a project
that smiles back at you
[Music]
the name comes from ada lovelace one of
the first computer programmers and the
linkages between weaving and computation
neediness is one of the earliest
examples of 3d printing additively
layering link by link row by row
material the project features soft forms
that are more feminine versus masculine
and that's a paradigm shift in
architecture the shape of Ada is an
ellipsoid it features a unique
exoskeleton composed of a network of
fiberglass rods and 3d printed nodes
every single node is different and has a
unique ID attached to it
[Music]
the interior surface is composed of
hundreds of digitally knit cones and
cells in a network of webbing in the
center of a des is a large tensegrities
cone composed of a skin of fiber optic
cables photoluminescent fiber absorbs
energy from the lighting and then emits
that back as knitted light as glowing
light but the real magic comes through
how people actually engage with it on
the interior soft surface is a whole
network of LEDs connected to a network
of cameras within the atrium reading the
facial expressions of people in an
anonymous way when building 99 is very
active the project will be very vibrant
and highly transformative there are
moments where it blushes
the hope is that people realize their
engagement is actually driving the
project that the project begins to gain
its own life in the way that it is
interacting with people
[Music]
okay so as you saw we just launched ADA
on Friday so we're really excited we
have no idea how this thing is going to
evolve but that's part of the idea right
that's why we're doing it we want to see
how it evolves and what kind of
conversations come up around it and
there's Eric I don't know if you can see
I mean right there it's true your neck
kind of hurts after a little while so
we'll work on that and also we're gonna
be building an open SDK so that we can
enable teams across research to actually
upload and plug-in their own datasets to
explore the way that their data is
volumize in sort of a dimensional form
so we're really excited about that so
that's it for me and this is my alias
you can ping me if you're interested and
I'll stick around a little bit at lunch
but I have to leave at 12:30 so thank
you and questions Coley ah yay cool
questions questions
hi that's pretty cool I have a question
about sustainability right so the idea
of this I'm assuming is large to provide
a new way to design cities so that we
are able to deal with the climate change
right at this curve you know it's like
more experimental but can you talk about
scalability like what is it needed to
you know move forward into making cities
that kind of look like these that's what
they need to look like or I don't know
yeah so I think the biggest one is cost
and men and manufacturing and
construction industries cement is really
cheap asphalt's really cheap right so as
long as those dollars are kind of the
newer materials are expensive it's gonna
be a hard to justify also 90-degree
angles and Cartesian angles are very
easy to do so these curved things are
just a lot more complex in nature and
until we have the material systems in
place that actually can do it without a
lot of effort I think there's going to
be some obstacles there but I honestly
predict in the next five or ten years we
are gonna see at least an emergency
housing these kind of things start to
show up right so they've already been
taking shipping containers and transit
and actually converting those into
dwellings so when there was the
earthquake in Japan they actually took a
bunch of cargo freight and they
converted them into small apartments so
we may see some stuff like that in the
beginning and then eventually look at
the way that you know big industries
like around construction will start to
adopt these things
hi this is a thought I had when I
interacted with the the installation and
I'll just tell you yeah sure um is that
I thought that it could also be a very
interesting exercise in empathy because
one of the ongoing conversations is
about how technologists are like in
their own ivory towers and you know
they're like not very engaged with
social and political realities and would
it be possible then to use the other
data source as a place that is far away
in imagination then effect and transmit
that effect on to basically these ivory
tower experts and kind of connect that's
to communities you can imagine you could
have some location right and sort of
that data set would be feeding you can
see how the town is feeling that day
right oh yeah basically so to generate
sort of political relationality
it would be really cool one thing we're
going to see with the patterns will we
will see any correlations with any sort
of social events going on around here in
our world you know even weather patterns
there's gonna be all kinds of things
that are gonna be threaded together
based on sort of overall but I love that
idea thank you oh we got one in the back
hi so I really love this so something I
kept thinking about while listening to
your talk is kind of that kind of the
work on my data data literacy and data
science and now people are taking this
more like Paulo Freire eeeh and super
critical ways of helping people kind of
think about who has your data who has
access to your data and like what are
you doing with your data
yeah and so I'm wondering so I'm
thinking about like so yesterday we
talked about like what is the future of
computing and we've talked a lot about
how a lot of the future of computing is
going to require people to have like a
like a sound amount of data literacy in
order to be like citizens and so I'm
wondering like the applications of this
type of work for like data literacy and
kind of like these more social justice
type of an equity type of issues yeah I
think I mean I think this is part of why
I'm sort of using the artisan residence
as sort of a bit of a Trojan horse to
have very candid conversations around
the effect that these technologies have
in our environments and with with with
all of us combined so I think that we're
open for that I think that's part of why
in the future we'd like to do more calls
so whether we invite you know writers or
artists or you know even political
activists to come in and just work with
us but use art as sort of that that
initial step you know so I don't I don't
know there we'll see how that evolves
yeah thank you okay thanks everyone
[Applause]
you